ja es geht um den gender pay gap gender
pay gap heißt auf deutsch
verdienstunterschied zwischen männern
und frauen verdienen frauen in
deutschland wo sie per gesetz
gleichberechtigt sind tatsächlich
weniger als männer
darüber streitet man sich
leidenschaftlich mit verschiedenen
zahlen frau und verdienen 21 prozent
weniger als männer es sind nur sechs
prozent weniger rein ist es noch weniger
weniger ich mag wie kann das sein
man kann sich noch nicht über zahlen
streiten takt das popcorn weg freunde
der sonne holte ich liebe einen tee
wir klären das jetzt in aller ruhe und
ein für alle mal willkommen beim imap
freunde der sonne der kanal auf dem wc
trinken und zwar nicht im sinne von spin
city sondern eher im sinne von abwarten
gewissermaßen denn der gender pay gap
ist so ein thema das chronisch
unvollständig dargestellt wird denn wie
so oft gibt es hier komplexere
zusammenhänge und wer dafür schon zeit
richtig wir das ist der plan worte macht
euch gemütlich und sie ist ein großer
teil des streits um den gender pay gap
entsteht allein dadurch dass die
mathematik hinter der statistik nicht
ganz klar
dabei ist sie eigentlich gar nicht so
kompliziert passiert warum gibt es für
den gender pay gap verschiedene zahlen
und damit sind wir auch schon mittendrin
im problem bzw in der verwirrung denn in
deutschland wird der gender pay gap ganz
offiziell auf zwei verschiedene art und
weisen berechnet und dabei kommen zwei
verschiedene zahlen raus erstens der
unbereinigte gender pay gap wir nehmen
den durchschnittlichen
bruttostundenverdienst aller männer und
vergleichen ihn mit dem
durchschnittlichen
bruttostundenverdienst aller frauen
und dabei kommen wir auf einen
unterschied von 21 prozent der
unbereinigte gender pay gap beträgt also
21 bzw
diese zahlen sind von 2017 die
berechnungen für 2018 kommen
aus diesen daten kommen vom
statistischen bundesamt und diese art
und weise der berechnung ist auch in
anderen eu ländern standard um den
gender pay gap zu berechnen in
deutschland wird daher am 18 märz der
equal pay day gefeiert
also was heißt gefahr so veranstaltet
auf der homepage heißt es auch 2009 10
werden frauen zum 18 märz wieder umsonst
arbeiten der equal pay day markiert also
21 prozent des jahres bis dahin arbeiten
frauen symbolisch also umsonst ich finde
die message des equal pay day ist
ziemlich missverständlich diese zahl
sagt uns nur dass der durchschnittsmann
21 prozent mehr verdient als sie durch
die frau sie sagt uns nicht achte ich
habe mir das extra besorgt und hier sind
keine batterien dabei egal ein visuelles
achtung achtung diese zahl sagt nicht
dass frauen für dieselbe arbeit 21
prozent weniger verdienen als männer und
deswegen berechnet das statistische
bundesamt noch eine zweite zahl zweitens
der bereinigte gender pay gap sowie man
jetzt folgendes wir nehmen diese 21 und
fragen uns was sind die gründe für
diesen unterschied beispiel denn jetzt
ärzte häufiger männer sind und
krankenpflege häufiger frauen dann wäre
das ein grund für den lohnunterschied zu
merken wir schon wir brauchen hier nicht
nur den brutto stundenlohn sondern alle
möglichen weiteren infos über die art
und weise der beschäftigung und weil
diese datenerhebung und auch die
auswertung recht aufwändig ist wird
diese ursachen erhebung vom
statistischen bundesamt nur alle vier
jahre gemacht ich habe jetzt für euch
die aktuellsten zahlen für das jahr 2014
die auswertung für 2018 kommt als
nächstes jahr aus hier sehen wir jetzt
frauen und männer verdienen
unterschiedlich viel weil frauen und
männer im schnitt unterschiedliche
arbeit machen zumindest erklären diese
unterschiede einen großen teil des
gender pay gap zu den wichtigsten
unterschieden zählen frauen verbringen
mehr zeit mit der erziehung der kinder
oder pflegen
deswegen frauen arbeiten öfter in
teilzeit oder unterbrechen ihre arbeit
denkt also nicht verwirren lassen wir
vergleichen hier stundenlöhne aber
teilzeit oder geringfügige arbeit oder
auch arbeitsunterbrechungen die führen
nicht nur zu weniger arbeitszeit sondern
die gehen auch einher mit einem
niedrigeren stundenlohn im vergleich zur
vollzeit und frauen arbeiten er in
niedriger bezahlten berufen oder
positionen zb arbeiten männer er in gut
bezahlten branchen wie ingenieurwesen
oder frauen in niedrig bezahlten
branchen wie erziehung pflege
sozialarbeit doch auch in derselben
branche oder auch im selben beruf haben
männer häufiger führungspositionen oder
andere höher bezahlte positionen frauen
seltener und auch das hängt damit
zusammen dass frauen insgesamt einen
geringeren arbeitsumfang haben denn
führungspositionen oder andere höhe
bezahlte positionen die setzen oft voll
zeit voraus wenn nicht sogar überstunden
so ein großer teil ist denn der paid
apps lässt sich also logisch erklären
doch ein teil bleibt unerklärt diese
unerklärte gender pay gap ist der
sogenannte bereinigte der pegel wenn man
jetzt also alle möglichen unterschiede
daraus rechnet wie qualifizierung
berufswahl position und vieles andere
dann bleibt immer noch ein
lohnunterschied zurück dieser bereinigte
gender pay gap betrug 2014 sechs prozent
21 und 6 prozent sind also die beiden
offiziellen zahlen des statistischen
bundesamtes immer wieder gibt es auch
noch andere zahlen die in der
öffentlichen diskussion kursieren zum
beispiel hat das institut der deutschen
wirtschaft iw in seinen eigenen
berechnungen ein gender pay gap von
gerade einmal 3,8 rausbekommen sie haben
einen anderen datensatz dafür verwendet
und auch eine andere methode der
berechnung die jetzt öffentlich nicht im
detail einsehbar ist damit wir uns jetzt
nicht streiten müssen ob die
berechnungen des iw es unabhängig und
damit verlässlich sind denn das muss man
als wirtschaftlichen interessen verband
betrachten halte ich es für sinnvoll
dass wir uns einfach auf die zahlen des
statistischen bundesamt
das konzentrieren also zwei verschiedene
zahlen sie ja schon genug verführung und
damit kommen wir zu eigentlich wichtigen
frage welche zahl ist die richtige beide
zahlen 21 prozent und sechs prozent
haben ihre berechtigung denn sie sagen
etwas unterschiedliches aus manche
halten den bereinigten gender pay gap
also die kleinere zahl für
aussagekräftiger denner sagt frauen
verdienen bei vergleichbarer arbeit 6
prozent weniger als männer
echte man jetzt mit sechs prozent statt
mit 21% dann wäre der equal pay day in
deutschland nicht dem achtzehnten märz
sondern am 22 januar die situation ist
also nicht so unfair und schockierend
wie es manchmal vermittelt oder
verstanden wird aber trotzdem warum
kriegen frauen immer noch 6 prozent
weniger als männer
diskriminierung kann ein grund sein das
hat zb diese amerikanische studie
man nahm sich hochschul professorinnen
und professoren und sagte ihnen schauen
sie sich bitte diesen lebenslauf an und
stellen sie sich vor diese person
bewirbt sich bei ihnen als der ball
manager was die post aber nicht wussten
ist das ist in wirklichkeit zwei
verschiedene lebensläufe gehabt die
komplett identisch waren es gab auch
kein foto
nur die vornamen der bewerber waren
verschieden einmal jennifer und einmal
john manche bekam dörfer manche bekamen
schon interessante reise wurde jennifer
im schnitt als weniger kompetent und
geeignet für den job bewertet und ihr
wurde auch weniger mentoring also
betreuung und entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
angeboten dafür bekannt john deutlich
mehr statt gehalt nur achtung achtung
hier grafik ist täuschend der
gehaltsunterschied es nicht so groß wie
auf den ersten blick erscheint der die
y-achse nicht bei null anfängt aber wir
haben hier einen unterschied von 30.000
versus 26.000 was natürlich trotzdem
nicht erst diskriminierung ist real aber
das allein reicht noch nicht aus um den
bereinigten gender pay gap zu erklären
sonst hieß es ja auch nicht unerklärte
rest sondern diskriminierung es gibt
eine reihe von eigenschaften die
einfluss auf die lohnhöhe haben können
aber nicht ohren nicht messen kann wie
zum beispiel risikobereitschaft oder
opportunistisches verhalten oder
selbstbewusstsein in
vertragsverhandlungen und so weiter gibt
es dadurch unterschiede zwischen männern
und frauen
die meisten würden wahrscheinlich hier
vom gefühl her sagen ja nur sind diese
unterschiede groß genug um einfluss auf
die durchschnittlichen lohn höhen zu
haben
vielleicht ja vielleicht nein vielleicht
manchmal auch hier gilt wenn das ding
wissenschaftlich erklärt wäre dann würde
es nicht unerklärt heißen bevor wir uns
hier also vermutungen als fakten
gegenseitig vor den kopf knallen
warten wir doch lieber auf weitere
aufklärung der unbereinigte gender theke
hat einen anderen fokus er sagt frauen
verdienen im schnitt 21 prozent weniger
als männer
vor allem weil sie sich unterschiedlich
entscheiden verhalten oder handel diese
gründe kann man wie gesagt statistisch
nachvollziehen und in ihnen steckt wie
ich finde eine ganz interessante
schlussfolgerung nämlich zeit für
familie sei es für die erziehung der
kinder oder die pflege der alten diese
zeit hat ihren preis
es ist immer ein trader entweder zeit
oder lohn also zeit ist geld im sinne
von man muss seine zeit bezahlen mit
einem niedrigeren lohn das kann man
jetzt als finanzielle frauen
benachteiligung sehen oder man sieht es
etwas allgemeiner als finanzielle
erziehungs und pflege benachteiligung
ist das fair
lassen wir mal die altenpflege außen vor
dann gibt es hierzu das häufige argument
kinderkriegen ist privatvergnügen und
privat ballast eines jeden einzelnen
es wird niemand dazu gezwungen kinder zu
kriegen und diesen trade off zu machen
das finde ich ein bisschen kurz gedacht
weil kinder in verdammt wichtiger teil
unserer gesellschaft sind und ihre
erziehung und entwicklung ist nicht nur
privatsache sondern hat auch direkten
einfluss auf die gesamtgesellschaft vor
allem in einem land in dem zum beispiel
das rentensystem
generationenvertrag beruht das heißt
dass wir überhaupt kinder kriegen und
dass wir uns um sie kümmern
daran sollte allgemeines interesse
bestehen aber der wichtigste gedanke
fehlt noch und zwar niemand zwingt ja
die frauen dazu mehr elternzeit zu
nehmen als die männer oder öfter in
teilzeit zu arbeiten klar natürlich
frauen haben noch die schwangerschaft
aber schaut man jetzt mit ihnen die usa
zum beispiel sieht man dass dort frauen
auch bis kurz vorm bindung noch arbeiten
gehen und dann weniger als ein monat
elternzeit nehmen also ob das jetzt gut
ist das ist noch mal eine ganz andere
debatte ich will damit nur sagen dass
weder gesetzlich noch biologisch frauen
dazu gezwungen sind so viel zu hause zu
bleiben wie sie es im durchschnitt tun
kann man also argumentieren frauen sind
ja selbst schuld und verantwortlich für
die entscheidungen die sie treffen und
damit freunde der sonne kommen wir jetzt
endlich achtung achtung zum eigentlichen
knackpunkt dieser ganzen gender pay gap
debatte entscheidungsfreiheit schauen
wir noch mal in die ursachen erhebung
sehen wir dass es nur kleine
durchschnitts unterschiede zwischen
männern und frauen in sachen ausbildung
und qualifizierung gibt wir können also
eher ausschließen dass frauen niedrig
bezahlte jobs nehmen weil ihnen die
ausbildung für höheres fehlt am ende
sind es die entscheidungen die frauen
und männer für ihr berufsleben treffen
und hier steckt das größte
streitpotenzial der man kann hier im
grunde zwei verschiedene positionen
vertreten position frauen und männer
entscheidend frei über ihre berufswahl
und familienzeit vollen hausfrau haus
waren bis hin zur ehefrau karriere man
die meisten menschen entscheiden sich
für das was sie am liebsten machen
wollen und frauen und männer wollen im
schnitt einfach verschiedene sachen oder
position b frauen und männer unterliegen
jeweils gesellschaftlichen zwängen zum
beispiel frauen verspüren druck für die
familie zu sorgen und männer verspüren
trug das geld nach hause zu bringen und
das alles hält sie davon ab das zu tun
was sie eigentlich tun möchten das ist
jetzt der punkt wo die fronten besonders
verhärtet erscheinen denn bisher war es
ja noch schön bis hierhin hatten wir
zahlen jetzt haben wir keine zahlen mehr
mit deren hilfe wir diskutieren können
trotzdem kann man sich einfach ein paar
logische gedanken zu
entscheidungsfreiheit machen und ich
möchte zwei davon mal in den raum werfen
erstens entscheidungsfreiheit auf dem
papier führt nicht automatisch zu
entscheidungsfreiheit in der praxis
echtes beispiel für euch ich habe eine
zeit lang in den usa gelebt wo der
arbeitnehmerschutz im vergleich zu
deutschland miserabel ist in boston gab
es ein start up das irgendwann unlimited
holidays eingeführt hat unbegrenzte
urlaubstage keine regel alle freiheit
man konnte selbstbestimmt entscheiden ob
man jetzt ein halbes jahr urlaub nimmt
oder nur nur woche was glaubt ihr ist
passiert leute haben weniger urlaub
genommen als anderswo weil natürlich
niemand der deb sein wollte der vaude
der selbstbestimmt mehr urlaub nimmt als
seine fleißigen kollegen und im
zweifelsfall entlassung riskiert
zweitens soziale unterschiede haben
einen hamsterrad effekt vor nicht allzu
langer zeit waren frauen zu hause und
männer gegen arbeiten punkt seitdem ist
viel passiert
doch nehmen jetzt mal ein durchschnitts
paar von heute bei dem der mann mehr
verdient als die frau und dieses paar
entscheidet sich jetzt für ein kind und
dafür dass ein elternteil zu hause bei
dem kind bleiben sollte oder zumindest
viel zeit und verbringen sollte wie
teilen sie sich jetzt auf rein
wirtschaftlich betrachtet ist nur eine
sache sind voll nämlich dass der mann
der mehr verdient nicht weniger arbeitet
sondern die frau die er weniger verdient
man kann sich natürlich frei andersrum
entscheiden aber das muss man sich erst
mal leisten können das heißt der mann
geht weiter arbeiten er kann weiter
berufs und betriebserfahrung sammeln er
kann auf eine gehaltserhöhung oder eine
beförderung hinarbeiten die frau nicht
folge die lohnlücke zwischen den beiden
wird in zukunft nur größer dass
unterschiedliche ausgangssituationen
reproduzieren unterschiede
das waren jetzt zwei beispiele von
vielen für äußere zwänge die nicht ganz
einfach zu durchbrechen sind nur kann
man jetzt alles
mit äußeren zwängen erklären oder sind
frauen männer im durchschnitt dann doch
so unterschiedlich dass sie sich auch
unterschiedlich verhalten würden wenn es
keine größeren zwinge gelb und was
eigentlich den männern ich mein geld ist
jetzt nicht das einzig wertvolle dass
wir haben sondern zeit ist ja genau so
wertvoll auch zeit mit der familie kann
man den gender pay gap nicht vielleicht
auch als gender precious time with your
family gap betrachten außerdem es gibt
das argument frauen verdienen nicht
weniger sondern sie bekommen weniger
gehalt wegen ihrer berufswahl was soll
man wiederum verdient im sinne von fair
ist ist es denn fair dass beruf in
branchen wie erziehung pflege
sozialarbeit die für unsere gesellschaft
zweifelsfrei wichtig sind so niedrig
bezahlt sind ist ein krankenpfleger
tatsächlich fair entlohnt auch darüber
kann man streiten finde ich konstruktiv
streiten versteht sich ihr werdet es
nicht glauben ich habe noch übrig aber
konstruktiv streiten das ist jetzt euer
stichwort die kommentare sind wir immer
eröffnet persönliche meile und sind
willkommen verschiedene der meinung sind
auch willkommen
nur bitte verkauft euch eure
persönlichen meinungen als fakten das
machen freunde der sonne nicht aber
wisst ihr auch bescheid ich freue mich
darauf von euch zu lesen es fühlt sich
sehr gut an wieder zurück zu sein
wir sehen uns nächsten donnerstag bis
dann
sicher